today we're going to talk about the
evolution of or I guess how it is that
evolutionary biology makes sense of this
phenomenon of homosexuality mainly
sexual orientation and this is a
question that I get asked a lot
I want to start by just talking about
homosexuality or homosexual behavior in
other organisms
like how common is I guess there's a
there's a there is a difference between
homosexual behavior and then actual like
homosexual orientation I don't know if
we can tease that apart in animals but I
guess just
what is the research in other animals
around homosexuality
right uh that's a that's a really big
question so like we can only maybe
sketch out a few a few relatively uh you
know summary pictures of what that looks
like but
um
so so in the research literature there's
been estimates that have ranged you know
in the well upwards of a thousand I mean
like I've you see the number a lot in
the in the research literature that as
many as like 1500 give or take animal
species have been you know observed to
have uh engaged in some sort of same-sex
behavior and uh you know you mentioned
the question of like can you tease apart
like
um homosexuality as the orientation
versus like same-sex behavior
um more broadly and uh so it's a little
bit difficult in some cases like you
know we can't get inside you know the
head of other species if we can't really
communicate that with them using you
know our own you know human languages
but
um that being said though there are some
species that practice monogamous mating
uh and you know there's a number of
species where it's been observed that
there are
um
on on one hand you can say like same-sex
Behavior as just like a behavior that
animals you know will sometimes engaged
in engage in and it doesn't really mean
anything in terms of like what we would
think of as being like having a sexual
orientation but in other contexts you
can also see instances where
organisms seem to engage in same-sex
Behavior you know preferentially or like
you know they're more likely to or they
do so more often uh and then I'll go
again I'm speaking like uh
like specific instances like it's not I
don't think there's any species where
like you know everyone's homosexual but
um there are at least you know you can
look at behavioral Trends or behavioral
patterns and say okay some members of
this species are you know more prone to
same-sexual behavior than they are prone
to opposite sex behavior and I would say
that is something more akin to what we
would recognize amongst ourselves as
being like homosexual
there are you know some species for
example that engage in same-sex error
bonding and that's much more than just
like a quick little in the moment
same-sex Behavior yeah yeah there's that
really varies by species sorry go ahead
when I was at the so I used to volunteer
at zoos that's actually kind of how I
got into Science Education as I started
out volunteering at zoos and I've I
lived in Tennessee for a while and I was
volunteering at the at the Knoxville Zoo
and we okay we had a there was a couple
of owls there that it was there were two
males that that pair bonded and they
were they were really really close I
mean they had
I'm actually not sure in that case if it
was uh
if they were alone there together and
that's why they pair bonded or if I
I seem to remember that that there were
there were females to choose from but
the the males pair bonded and they just
and they would build a nest they would
guard their nest they wouldn't interact
with other owls very much
um and we were actually not supposed to
tell people about that unless they asked
because it caused
like people didn't like it if you were
telling their kids that the the owls
were both male
um so I thought that was interesting
people were people were very
uncomfortable about that
um I and I know that this happens a lot
in captivity with birds especially birds
will pair bond and and a lot of bird
species pair bond for Life uh
I I just had to mute myself earlier here
because my dogs were barking and my dogs
are actually really interesting because
so I've I have a female dog and a male
dog
the my male dog does something that I
have I try to look in the literature to
see if anyone's documented this before
because it's I filmed it I've I'll have
to put up a film of this sometime
because it's it's super interesting
he is fixed
uh she is not she was we got her from a
breeder she was being used to to breed
dogs and she was older and so we just
were like ah we just won't bother fixing
her we'll just deal with her being in
heat every once in a while well we take
him to the dog park a lot but obviously
not when she's in heat that would be a
problem but uh when she's in heat they
will mate he's fixed so you know there's
no there's no chance of her getting
pregnant but they'll mate and when he's
been mating with her he is extremely
jealous he does a typical mate guarding
behaviors which are well documented in
dogs where they'll like it when when the
female urinates the male will urinate
over her urine
um he if you if you pick up the our Zoe
our our female dog you put her back down
he'll go Sniff and make sure that she
didn't just like uh mate with someone I
mean he's very he's just on top of it
after she's
out of heat and we can start taking her
to the dog park again
he is extremely jealous still for eight
probably lasts about two months and what
he does to for mate guarding if a male
shows interest in him he will go present
as a female and he'll bump against them
and start getting them to to try and
copulate with him it's it's
like
it seems like this is like a
I think most biologists if they were to
see that in the wild they would document
that as homosexual Behavior but in the
context it seems like it's a it's a form
of mate guarding it's really interesting
so I've not seen anyone document that
it's it's not in the literature anywhere
but that's what my dog does is if it
appears to be a form of mate guarding so
I'm really curious to see to to hear if
if anyone is is uh ever seen that
elsewhere uh
but it's um I'll have to upload a video
of it because it's it's really obvious
what's happening when you when you watch
it and it makes people at the dog park
uncomfortable and it's it's just kind of
a funny situation but
the
yeah that's actually proposed as one of
the possible hypotheses to explain
same-sex Behavior at least in some
animals yeah that would be the example
of uh intra-sexual conflict like you
know conflict between males for example
yeah yeah like you said the idea being
you know individuals might you know
reduce the reproductive success of
competitors right
through same-sex Behavior
but and that would be an Adaptive an
Adaptive explanation for homosexual
behavior
um but we don't we don't necessarily
need an Adaptive explanation for it
there there are other uh hypotheses as
as we're going to go over here
for uh
for
uh homosexual orientation
of
so so you're saying that that this is
observed in thousands of animals the
homosexual Behavior at least and then we
have in individuals we have every once
in a while you'll you'll get long-term
same-sex pair bonding so either two
females or two males
um right
are there you said that there are some
species where it's more prominent than
others uh
which species specifically are you
mentioning there
uh well the ones that come to mind most
easily for me are would be Birds right
because like there's a social monogamy
you know monogamous pair bonding is
really common in birds and
um actually there's different kinds of
uh monogamy right there's social
monogamy where you might have a pair of
bond just between two adults that stay
together throughout throughout their
lifespan yeah and that you would call
social monogamy and that's actually
technically distinct from sexual
monogamy and so like there's a lot of
examples of birds that are uh socially
monogamous but they're not sexually
monogamous yeah and uh so that uh that
would be I guess you could almost think
of that as uh like in in human language
should be able to be almost like having
an open relationship I guess
um right but well I I I hesitate to
anthropomorphize
um Burns but but there is a distinction
between like social and sexual monogamy
yeah and um
yeah so those would be I think some of
my favorite examples in fact um
uh the the Quaker Parrot it's the little
green bird that's on my shoulder in the
um in my Twitter profile picture
um that's that species is known for
being socially monogamous and also
engages in in made gardening like my
Quaker Parrot hates my romantic partner
yeah and well I don't know it hates is
the right word but just is a lot more
aggressive and is a lot more like
um you know uh possessive of me I guess
you could say yeah and
um these but but this bird species is
also known to engage in what we would
call extra parapeternity right right so
like
um you know how the cuckoo bird is kind
of parasitic in the sense that it can
like it'll it'll tend to lay an egg in
the nest of some other species and then
have the
uh the birds of that other species raise
its own young yeah uh well the Quaker
Parrot has been reported as in the
literature is doing that to other
members of its own species where it'll
just engage in extra pair paternity and
you know drop its its young off to be
raised by some other uh members of the
same species yeah
so there's there's I guess uh sorry I'm
getting off on a tangent but I guess my
point being like there's a lot of
monogamous parabonding that occurs in
animals and I think at least you know
I'm I'm more familiar with birds than I
am with a lot of other taxonomic
lineages so you know my answer might be
a little bit biased uh in terms of like
the degree of representation among taxa
but but yeah there's species that
um there's quite a lot of species
actually that engage in monogamous pair
bonding yeah
I I believe uh cetaceans which are you
know whales and dolphins also also do as
well quite commonly and of course that
you know sexual same-sex behaviors
observed quite frequently in in
cetaceans as well
yeah what in uh in dogs and in wolves
that
one of the reasons that make guarding is
so common in dogs and in wolves is
because the males will feed the female
I'm not sure if they I think in wolves
they also feed the pups but for sure
they feed the female when she's nursing
so it's a huge personal investment for
the male in The Offspring and so right
you can think of how make guarding would
evolve it's just the the males that
don't
that don't make guard are oftentimes
going to be raising puppies that are not
theirs and so their genes aren't going
to be passed on and males that do mate
guard are more likely to be actually
actually be raising their own puppies so
they're that trait of mate guarding will
get passed on so you can get the
evolution of mate guarding instincts
that dogs still show
that's interesting so you're saying that
the the Quaker Parrot I actually had a
sun conure parrot for a while and uh oh
cool and he was the same he was very
aggressive uh
actually it was kind of seasonal he
would it depended on the season uh
because they have you know they they go
through like a a mating season and he
was male and in males in Sun Conure
parrots they actually their hormones
completely change when they're during
mating season and not in mating season
their their testicles shrink everything
like shuts down
which meant I don't know maybe that's
like a a weight saving
adaptation since birds have to fly so
much but that's what it was described to
as me but but he would at certain times
of the year he'd become super aggressive
towards anyone who was not me but I have
an identical twin brother
and so he would hang out with both of us
just fine he'd just fly back and forth
and be kind of confused he'd think that
my brother is me and uh that was the
only person he could get along with when
he was I guess you'd say in heat but
yeah that's that is interesting the the
mate guarding in parrots
I I guess that must be an adaptation for
um like what you were saying before
it must be common in in most and many
species of parrots than for
um
for males to spend resources raising
babies that aren't theirs which is that
that's what would get the
that's what would drive mate guarding to
evolve yeah
uh and then so so that's that's as far
as parent bonding goes and so so you can
get um you can get social monogamy you
can get same-sex social monogamy as you
were saying
um but would you say that's that's less
common than male female social monogamy
and birds
uh same-sex pair bonding is less common
in Birds yeah I would definitely say so
um
and then we have
there there are some animals that just
do a lot of homosexual behaviors I know
hyenas are one example where the females
there's a lot of uh female female sexual
activity in hyenas
you have giraffes behind you and the
picture behind you there I seem to
remember hearing that there's a lot of
male male sexual activity with giraffes
I don't know if you've looked into that
but
uh yeah though I mean that wouldn't
surprise me I couldn't say off the top
of my head whether uh what what the
evidence is for for giraffes but uh but
I mean you're absolutely right like this
is observed in so many species like you
know fish and echinoderms you know
starfish and sea urchins and um
you know squids uh
and not that squids are a kind of terms
you know they're cephalopods but you
know there's a whole bunch of different
types of marine life you know and then
as well as uh you know insects and
reptiles you know Birds different
species of mammal you know it's been
observed pretty much across the gamut of
uh of animal Texa same-sex behavior that
is yeah yeah
so let's talk about it in humans now
um sure and by the way if anyone has
questions feel free to uh put those
questions in the comments here we'll get
to questions later on
but let's talk about homosexuality in
humans again
um there's going to be homosexual
behavior and then homosexual pair
bonding in humans or I guess
you know it's considered homosexual
orientation right maybe I guess maybe we
should talk about the difference between
homosexual orientation and homosexual
behavior in humans maybe that would be a
good way good spot to start
yeah so I mean I I think the simplest
way to think of it is just that the
homosexual orientation refers to like
who you're attracted to right and so
that's
um you know whatever it kind of precedes
Behavior like in the sense that you know
people tend to gravitate uh when it
comes to sexual behavior people tend to
gravitate towards people that are
attracted to right so like you can
conceptually draw a line of distinction
between behavior and orientation but uh
they're they're frequently related at
least in humans because you know we you
know I think almost all cultures are you
know have a a general Norm of
you know tending to to uh
I guess uh try to pursue relationships
with people they're attracted to right
so yeah
well we have um we have like situational
homosexuality in prison systems for
example and I think that might actually
be what happens a lot of times in zoos
when you see um animals doing same-sex
pair bonding too is uh a lot of times
prisoners who are engaged even in
long-term homosexual relationships
they'll say that they're not homosexual
so that that they've they've formed this
um
Bond because that's the only option
available to them uh
and
a lot of older like with in in America
in the United States I mean my uncle's
in this situation
he got married to a woman he was he was
gay he was he was only attracted to men
but he got married to a woman because it
was so unacceptable at the time so you
have
in that case I guess situational
heterosexuality where you know he he
fathered child but it was just very
difficult for him and I mean if you talk
to people in the prison situation
whether and in the opposite situation
it's very difficult for them so there's
there's uh
I would I would say that in those cases
yeah there's there's a difference
between the uh
yeah Stark difference between behavior
and orientation right
um right yeah I wouldn't generalize to a
sorry I wouldn't generalize from a from
a confining situation like being in
prison to yeah human behavior more more
broadly uh that's for sure yeah
uh how common is
homosexual orientation in humans do we
have a good idea of that uh and I guess
also how
how intent I know that there's a there's
a scale that was at the Kings Kingsley
scale
scale that I was reading about so yeah
which is um where people are rated on a
whole number of questions on their
sexual orientation so
am I getting that right because I'm new
to this research I was just kind of like
crash course before we we uh we had this
meeting but so that's a scale from zero
to six zero being fully heterosexual six
being fully homosexual
and the
the article I was reading about it
showed that men are typically either
zeros or sixes
a smaller percentage are
are
that obviously a majority of men are
zeros at like zero zero through three
and then you have
um you have quite a few
I think it was like 10 to the study that
I was reading of men that are six so
they're fully homosexual
and then you with women things were a
little bit more there's a little bit
more margins so there was a little bit
more fluidity for women in the article
that I was reading I don't know if
that's uh like consistent in studies
that have been done
yeah so there's uh there's one study by
uh I I hope I'm not just pronouncing
this but I might be uh kazir Rahman
uh and colleagues um and by the way I
can I'm happy to send the the a lot of
the literature to you like some some
papers that I might reference during
this conversation I'm happy to share
with you if you wanted to yeah like I'll
post to them under this video or
something yeah yeah I'll put I'll put uh
links in the video description
okay great um but yeah there was a study
just a couple years ago in the Journal
archives of sexual behavior where they
looked at the prevalence of sexual
orientation across you know dozens of
countries and uh you know
North America Europe Asia the Pacific
Islands you know just pretty much across
the world uh except I don't I don't
think they looked in Africa
but uh they found that pretty much
across the board the the the
prevalence of homosexuality then the
people who like report being you know
gay or lesbian orientation
right
um is uh generally tends to be you know
in in the low to mid uh well yeah mid
single digits like I think it was almost
always somewhere between like three and
eleven percent okay and then um and then
it's on I mean it varies by country but
on average it's slightly higher for
people that report being bisexual and
then of course the majority uh remaining
is is people who report being straight
but I think the the interesting thing
about this type of research is that it
kind of parallels what we see in in the
sense of same-sex behavior in animals
where we see it's
exists at relatively low but
nevertheless kind of universal
prevalence across different FAFSA and
then like also if you zoom in on on you
know humans
even across different cultures around
the world we still see it at at you know
it's it's a minority but it's still a
very widely prevalent
uh
phenomenon I guess you could say yeah
you know that people are people you know
people you know India you know the
Philippines you know almost every
country we've looked at you know we see
a a low but nevertheless persistent uh
minority of people who are gay and
bisexual yeah
yeah I I feel like when when people ask
me questions about is if is there a gay
gene what they're trying to get at is
they're trying to ask is homosexuality
natural and I
um
the
just the fact that we see this
cross-cultural is that huge indication
that that yes it is uh even before we
had any of the the research and then of
course you could just ask someone like
is this natural resistor choice and they
they can tell you
um but the and that was actually one of
the one of the responses I would give to
people in the past was like well
if you ask people they'll tell you that
it's natural for them so I don't see any
reason not to believe them
but a lot of people do want this extra
uh evidence they want this genetic
evidence before they're willing to
accept it uh which
I don't know it just where we're at in
our country I I feel like things are a
lot more accepting nowadays than they
were for my uncle but of course there's
still a lot of uh
there's still a lot of people who are
very uncomfortable with homosexuality
and are trying to
still having trouble accepting that it's
even could be possibly real
uh
yeah things have gotten better for the
lgbtq community relative to where we
were you know Generations ago like you
say but we still have a long way to go
yeah in Western Community Western
um yeah that's right yeah
so you mentioned the Philippines
um it's how is homosexuality
um accepted more in other cultures than
it is here like
uh I would definitely say well I guess
it depends on what you mean by here but
because like I
uh you know it I think like whether or
not we would view the West as being like
culturally homogeneous or like a bunch
of different cultures I think kind of
varies by like what's the context of
what we're talking about but like yeah
um you know the United States tends to
be a lot more of in of an
individualistic culture for example than
let's say Europe so like in some
respects
um you know Western Europe is is
culturally different than than North
America even though we would both
consider them to be like the West yeah
and uh so like in that respect um you
know homosexuality
historically tends to be more accepted
in places that are more left-leaning
politically in in other ways
um you know like in ways that are that
are topically like different independent
uh sexual orientation
yeah
[Music]
yeah so and and then of course there's
there's uh
there have been
uh instances where well there's this
idea that like okay so I'm not a
historian of India but my my
um limited understanding is that
um there's this
um hypothesis that that sexual
orientation or that homosexuality is
largely viewed negatively they're
um partly because of the influence of
British colonialization like yeah back
to like ancient India then then
homosexuality is understood to have been
more accepted than uh then then
following
um colonialization
yeah that's I was reading about that in
different African colonies as well that
that there was a it was way more
accepted in the past yeah
that's such an unfortunate consequence
of of all this
right yeah
uh
well let's talk about let's talk about
the
evolutionary explanation so so we have
the observations that we have here is
that homosexuality homosexual behavior
is common in mammals it's common in
Birds uh long-term homosexual pair
bonding is when I say common I mean it's
it exists it's it's always a a low
percentage but it exists uh we see that
in in animals that do pair bonding so
birds and and so on
and humans were at you said between
three and ten percent is where things
tend to shake out in these surveys
yeah I mean you get like a distribution
but that seems to be uh where most where
most countries Fall that have been
looked at yeah and these are these are
through multiple questions to try and
break through
um like uh people
not being comfortable talking about it
and so on so yeah between three and ten
percent that I mean that's that's very
consistent
so what that suggests is that there must
be some sort of a genetic component to
this
and right if that's the case the
question is why does natural selection
not select against this until it's it
does not exist in a population and so
there are multiple different different
uh hypotheses for that that
without looking at the data like what
are what are those the different
explanations for this that that we could
hypothesize about
right so uh there's actually a I mean
there's like a over a dozen different
proposed explanations for the existence
of same-sex behavior and homosexuality
uh you know if you if you were to group
those together there's you know over a
dozen different explanations that I've
Rose uh but most likely uh the most
likely thing is that we probably need
multiple different hypotheses to be true
in order to be able to account for all
the data we see because uh you know
various phenomena might have different
explanations depending on the context or
depending on the situation depending on
the species for example
um and and the culture that being said
though like
uh to give you one example
it's
um it's been uh well so one observation
that's been uh reproducibly seen and
reported in the literature by different
studies is that uh in the case of gay
men and unfortunately
um homosexuality in males has been
looked out a lot more than uh
homosexuality in women and so that's
actually kind of a a
area like I guess you can say it like
that like a hole in the research where
we need more data to fill it but
um there although there are some uh
exceptions to that I'm happy to talk
about some studies that I've looked at
on the sexuality in women but
um if we if we start with the case of
like homosexuality in men one one
finding that's been reproducibly
reported in the literature is that uh
gay men on average have more older
brothers than straight men
and again this varies by from person to
person this is these are like
statistical averages across the
population so of course they're going to
be people that are straight but they
have a ton of older brothers and there
might be people who are an only child
and they're gay but you know
statistically you know
um and and the one of the explanations
for this is called the Fraternal birth
order effect and the the idea is that uh
the more times a woman is pregnant with
a male fetus over time it it
cumulatively increases the likelihood
that the the next Sun she has somewhere
down the line is going to end up being
gay and that would be an example of um
uh
that that tends to be explained more in
terms of like a hormonal explanation
rather than something that's genetically
inherited from our distant ancestors all
right and then on on the more yeah sorry
go ahead or I I guess that would be like
it's uh it's the genetics of the mother
um not the genetics of not the actual
Genome of the the gay male and that in
that circumstance it would be there's
something in the mother's genes that's
causing her to uh I guess change the
environment everybody to
that would induce uh homosexuality and
one of her sons
right yeah so when that was when this
finding was first I guess starting to
some be something that people were
taking notice of like in the sexual
orientation research
uh it was it was uh basically proposed
that it was a result of the the mother's
immune system uh basically reacting to
the presence of the Y chromosome in her
uterus interesting and or some something
on the Y chromosome like a y linked
histocompatibility complex they call it
and um and so you know there's there's
other examples where you know
over time successive
exposures to something can strengthen
the immune response to the thing that
you're being exposed to and so it's
thought that perhaps this is something
that can help explain the increase that
like the the progressively increasing
likelihood with successive pregnancies
that the next male son is going to be
gay
um there there is actually ironically a
potential evolutionary explanation for
that although I think the data is very
limited if there even is any data at all
but one possible evolutionary angle to
that is that uh you you could maybe take
a step back and say that as the
family grows the sorry let me back up if
we were to assume for the sake of
argument that like being gay is a proxy
for having a reduced likelihood of being
reproductive yeah or you know being
reproductively active because that's not
necessarily the case yeah
it's not necessarily the case but let's
let's just assume that for the sake of
argument then you could say that as a
family size increases
you know so does the likelihood the
likelihood also increases that uh later
Suns further down the chain are going to
be
um
less reproductively active you know and
so you could imagine a uh well it's it's
pretty easy to piece together what could
be a potential adaptive significance of
that right like as family size grows the
number of mouths to feed uh also grows
and the number of individuals that are
potentially going to be also reproducing
in the Next Generation also grows and so
one way to perhaps um uh you know
I guess uh
I I don't like to to use like malthusian
language
um because it's like really really
outdated but
um but but uh to the extent that
it produces a a burden on the family to
try to care for uh not only the The
Offspring but the next generation of
Offspring uh subsequent to that then
then it it is potentially adaptively
significant to have some members of you
know the the extended family be
non-reproductively active so that they
can you know care for others and this
gets back to like the kin selection
hypothesis yeah but again that's this is
like really speculative right like I
don't I don't even know if there's any
data at all to support that there's an
evolutionary component to the Fraternal
birth order effect I only bring up the
Fraternal birth order effect actually to
say that there are proposed explanations
for male homosexuality that don't seem
to have any genetic basis um per se
right and uh right okay so
yeah oh well let's try and summarize
that then so and instead of trying to
think of homosexuality as an adaptation
you could just think of it as an effect
of the mother's immune system in this
case right
um right or you could also think of it
as a an adaptation under kin selection
where you've got uh you know
homosexuality as a trait that that that
allows for members of the family to
instead of reproducing help out with
other tasks of child rearing and you
know helping take care of the family uh
that have nothing to do with
reproduction and this is something that
we see in lots of animals that like
crows for example the siblings will stay
in the nest for sometimes several uh
several uh
years and help the mother take care of
children so they they will postpone
being reproductively active even when
it's physically possible for them to
they just behaviorally that they won't
do it and instead they help the mother
uh you see this in
lots of different uh dog species
actually too there's the the wild the
African dog will do that they'll
uh wolves will do that it's forced so
the the um the alpha female or the the
female who's when times are tough she
won't let the other females in the pack
get pregnant so she'll stop a mating
from happening
so you you see this is common in nature
can selection
um doing this bees are the obvious
example that the bees don't have E's and
ants yeah
but the you're saying there's not good
data for kin selection being the cause
of homosexuality so uh there's no sorry
just to clarify what what I mean is uh
kin selection being the cause of the
Fraternal birth order effect okay okay
all right that's the thing that I I
don't think has really been looked at
much at least I'm not familiar with any
papers that have really looked at that
in any depth yeah a cleaner there have
been papers that have looked at kin
selection more broadly as a proposed uh
contributing explanation not that it's
exhaustive but as a potential
contributor to homosexuality at least in
some contexts okay
but you're saying that the the birth
order thing it's it's cleaner to explain
this as a reaction of the immune system
because that's the data that we have
okay yeah that's yeah basically yeah and
I think that's uh the Fraternal birth
order effects and like how mixed the
data is in terms of like kin selection
being a contributor toward explaining
homosexuality I think is a good
opportunity to kind of highlight the
fact that
um like is there a gay gene is kind of a
big oversimplification right like the
idea that something is genetic doesn't
mean that genetic determinism is true
right like yeah our our genes are are
you know a biological organism is a
really dynamic system right like our
genes are constantly interacting with
their environment and so uh the whole I
mean even the whole idea of like nature
versus nurture is kind of a false
dichotomy like you know you have this
interaction between our environment that
we grow up in and the genes that we
inherit and it's the consequence of that
interaction that shapes who we are and
and uh including our sexual orientation
and so like it's that's probably never
going to be discovered that there's
actually a gay gene but that doesn't
mean that homosexuality isn't still
genetic because uh genetics does play a
role it's just not the complete picture
of the story right right
well and in this case it would be uh
an unrelated set of genes
the genes of the mother's immune system
that have evolved for completely
different reasons that might be causing
homosexuality in this case
that's really interesting yeah yeah
homosexuality caused by epigenetic
factors epigenetic for that for the
actual child uh genetic for the mother
yeah
but then they're at the same time there
have been
oh I mean there's a lot of evidence that
has shown that
um that there are very clearly uh
genetic components and in fact I didn't
even really in that original thread that
you mentioned on on Twitter
I didn't a lot like I purposefully
excluded talking about the Fraternal
birth order effects specifically because
the point of that threat was to focus on
like that question of why would
homosexuality be like so prevalent and
why would it be able to
evade Extinction right yeah if gay
people are less likely to have kids and
so I was more focusing on like what's
the research say about the evolutionary
components and so that kind of excluded
talking about the Fraternal birth order
effect or other potential explanations
for homosexuality but there is very that
being said though like there is really
good evidence that it is genetic like um
not only have there been twin studies
where
you can compare the statistical
likelihood that uh both twins have the
same sexual orientation if they're
fraternal twins versus if they're
identical twins yeah right and and um
and so the the if one twin is gay for
example the other twin is more likely to
be gay if they're identical twins than
if they're fraternal twins and so that's
one way to show that okay there does
seem to be some evidence for a genetic
component yeah and I would say even even
stronger than that is the evidence from
genome-wide Association studies and uh
and I I can talk a little bit about what
what those are uh if you would like but
you know suffice it to say that we see
some uh some some ways that you know the
DNA sequence varies from person to
person in the population and the way
that it varies from person to person is
statistically correlated with
um sexual orientation and that's another
source of evidence that that sexual
orientation has a a genetic component
right and in that in that case it's not
necessarily a single Gene like a single
stretch that you could find on one
chromosome but multiple interactions
from multiple genes and we'll talk about
that in a second here but before we move
on from the Fraternal birth order effect
um I've had a question just just to
re-explain what that means uh you
explained it once but maybe maybe we
went over it too quickly so
you just kind of reword what what that
is and how it works
okay yeah so it it's it came from the
um if I'm remembering the history of the
research Literature Like a lot of this
is before I even got into science but it
came from the
observation that uh gay males on average
tend to have more older brothers and
tend to come from larger families than
straight males you know all else being
equal and again this is like statistical
averages it's not true for everyone yeah
um and so the question is like well okay
why
um what is it about having more older
brothers that increases your likelihood
of being gay and uh the you know perhaps
the simplest explanation is that
um for any given pregnancy
if the if the fetus is male that just
seems to increase the likelihood that
the next feed is if it's male is going
to be gay
and um and so that's basically what the
Fraternal birth order effect is it's
just the idea that that
um a pregnancy with a male fetus
increases the likelihood that a future
pregnancy with a male fetus is going to
is going to uh produce someone who's gay
and uh and and so yeah I think the
strongest well well at least the the the
motivating evidence for that hypothesis
was that observation that that gay males
tend to have more older brothers and uh
that uh so like one of the sources of
well there's different uh I'm sorry I
think it might they might be a topic
that's complicated enough that we maybe
don't want to spend a lot of time on it
because like there's a whole bunch of
possible reasons that sort of come
together and
and like there's there's a phenomenon
called microchimerism where
um
uh women who have been pregnant have
been observed to have like really Trace
Amounts of Y chromosome yes and cells
and so like right yeah so like there's
there's an exchange of of
of tissue and DNA in between the mother
and fetus and so like there could even
be multiple different
um possible ways in which a pregnancy
can influence the outcome of future
pregnancies and
um and and so like I mentioned the the
why link to the Y chromosome-linked
histocompatibility
uh complex and the idea that
um the mother's immune system is is
being primed to influence the sexual
orientation of the the younger brother
if she's been pregnant with an older
brother with older brothers in the past
um you know that's one one possible
explanation and that could even be a
contributory
alongside other explanations yeah yeah
So Okay so we've got we we we've talked
about the
basically the non-genetic you know this
this is a an issue with uh
or it's caused by the the mother's
reaction to having multiple Sons
um
let's talk about some genetic causes for
this so there could be there could be
actual adaptive
uh genetic causes like can selection and
there could just be
non-adaptive consequences of multiple
genes interacting maybe we should
explore that idea
yeah sure so
there's like I said there's several
different you know over a dozen possible
explanations that have been proposed in
the literature for same-sex Behavior Uh
as far as like homosexuality as an
orientation in humans
uh from from what I've seen of the
literature the most
um
referred or like the leading candidate
explanations are in selection and then
what one of your commenters referred to
as I believe they refer to it as like
intra Locus conflict or uh what's often
referred to in the literature as uh as
sexually antagonistic selection or
sexual antagonism and
so the the idea with sexual antagonism
is that it refers to
um
uh again we're kind of getting into like
that that issue of potentially using
confusing language because like a lot of
anthropomorphic language is yeah uh used
like in biology but in this context the
the antagonism doesn't refer to like the
behavior of the organism it refers to
the effects of the genetic components
and so a a gene or or a set of genes
could have
uh conflicting effects depending on the
sex of the individual that inherits
those genes and that would be the
example of sexual antagonism yeah and um
so there's a lot of really really
fascinating examples that actually have
nothing to do with
um sexual orientation per se but make it
easier to kind of understand the general
concept and one of those would be uh
genetic traits that are inherited
maternally so like for example
mitochondrial DNA or in some species
there are bacterial reproductive
parasites like in arthropods especially
many many species of insect have this
bacterial parasite called wolbachia and
it's a reproductive parasite that is
inherited maternally just like you know
mitochondria are and because it's
inherited maternally it represents uh
sorry the the
um the male germline represents an
evolutionary dead end you know it's only
being passed by Phoenix from one
generation to the next okay and so if a
mutation were to happen
that has a uh a
a benefit to the reproductive Fitness of
females well it doesn't really matter if
as a byproduct it it is deleterious to
the reproductive Fitness of males for
example so that would be an example of
sexual antagonism and in the case of
that wolvakia species you know one of
the effects that have been observed is
the feminization of males there's also
male sterility or
um uh uh what do you call it
there's there's another one of them is
uh parthenogenesis right right where
where females can reproduce without even
needing males and uh so like the
wolbachia can can
um there's uh male lethality where they
can just kill males um but as long as it
doesn't harm females that you know the
wolvakia parasite doesn't care yeah you
know and in some cases mitochondria can
behave uh similarly and the phenomenon
is called the mother's curse right where
a mutation might have deleterious
effects in males but because
mitochondrial DNA is maternally
inherited you know the mitochondria
don't care if it hurts the males and so
by a similar token the genetics of
homosexuality could look something like
the following where uh the the actual
primary effect that is being uh favored
by natural selection is that there's an
element is that there's some genetic uh
trait or some you know combination of
genetic factors that lead to increased
birth rates among heterosexual women and
then as a byproduct they're the male
relatives of the heterosexual women
tends to be on average more likely to be
gay and one of the pieces of evidence
for that is that
we actually do see
again like on a population-wide
statistical average this isn't true in
every case but but like if we're just
talking in terms of like statistical
averages across the population
the uh we we do tend to see elevated
birth rates among the uh female
relatives of homosexual males and so
that's a very that's a piece of evidence
that is very strongly in favor of the
sexual antagonism hypothesis and so that
there's
uh the this finding of like elevated
birth rates um or elevated focundity
among the the relatives of homosexual
males is something that has been uh
reproducibly shown in multiple studies
in fact most of the studies I believe
that I shared in in that original
Twitter thread is like study after study
where they're like yes we see this
effect we see that on average males tend
to come from homosexual males tend to
come from large families they tend to uh
have moral or brothers they also tend to
be related to women who have who
experience or or exhibit higher birth
rates than the than the rest of the
population on average and and so this is
some of the evidence that weighs very
strongly in favor of sexual antagonism
uh effect being one of the key if not
the key evolutionary explanation and it
is at least one of the one of the
leading candidate explanations in the
literature for for male homosexuality
and like I said female homosexuality has
been studied a lot less but there is
some supporting evidence for that as
well in fact there's a paper one of the
papers that I shared in that thread I
believe it was titled possible balancing
selection in female homosexuality and
they look they see a very similar Trend
where where homosexual women on average
tend to be related to people who have
higher birth rates than average yeah and
so that could be like some uh balancing
effect where the genetic traits are
leading to higher birth rates which is
the increase in evolutionary Fitness
that favors those genetic traits and
then the byproduct is that in some
people it increases the likelihood of
homosexuality yeah I I think so the the
important and kind of tricky thing for
people to understand to under
underneath these Arguments for
um the genetic cause the Persistence of
genes that can cause homosexuality is
you really have to take a Gene's eye
view of this and it's the genes are the
things that are surviving in the
population
so specific specific types of genes and
it uh
a handful you can have multiple genes
that together when those are in a female
help her to be have lots of babies uh it
could it could affect her behavior in
some way it could affect how attracted
she is to men it could affect how
interested she is in having babies right
and when that same combination of genes
ends up in a male it might cause
homosexuality so because you have such a
fitness gain when that when that
combination exists in a female
those genes will persist in a population
even though every once in a while it
will produce a homosexual male who has
far fewer Offspring than his you know
his heterosexual peers so you can get
you can get this to persist in a
population over a long period of time
and that's really important because it's
important to understand that those
Dynamics can exist because if you just
think that there's a gay gene
and it's just normal mendelian genetics
of a single trait we would expect that
if homosexual men have fewer children
than heterosexual men which uh it's not
necessarily the case but it turns out
that because you know homosexual men
can't have heterosexual relationships
um and they can father children anyways
but it does turn out I was looking at
the the stats for this and it's
um
even even when there was cultural
pressure for gay men to get married they
were still having far fewer children in
the United States
the the stats were kind of confusing for
me to like that their study was a little
bit complicated but it the the numbers
were pretty clear that homosexuality was
reducing
um
a number of Offspring for men
even in cultures where there were
pressure to get married anyways
and so you have um
if this were just one gene mendelian
sorting uh we would expect it to
disappear really quickly but if it's
multiple genes that are having different
effects in females than they are in
males
this could this could persist
forever you know there's no there's no
selection pressure that could
we wouldn't expect selection pressures
to get rid of it if uh if the mothers
are
if the mothers that have these traits
are having more offspring
so
right yeah exactly and that that
explanation uh of you know sexual
antagonistic effects
has been looked at in a number of
different ways you know there's there's
one paper I'd be happy to share in fact
it's in the original Twitter thread
where they took like an evolutionary
modeling approach they basically did
like an evolutionary simulation to say
uh let's let's suppose for the sake of
argument that that is the explanation
that uh male homosexuality hangs around
as an evolutionary byproduct because the
underlying genetic factors are leading
to increased reproductive Fitness among
their relatives you know there there's
there's you know some research has
looked at that you know in a modeling
way where they run an evolutionary
simulation and say okay yes under under
a certain range of conditions I believe
um what they found if I'm remembering
the paper correctly was that
um as long as there's at least two
genomic loci and one of them is on the X
chromosome then yes this is a sufficient
evolutionary explanation to explain the
Persistence of male homosexuality and
they've also seen this in like I
mentioned a number of different
empirical studies where they just look
at birth rates among the the relatives
of homosexual males and then uh finally
they've also looked at this in other
species like for example uh one of the
most widely used laboratory organisms is
fruit flies right and believe it or not
fruit flies are also observes to engage
in um well they engage in courtship
Behavior but one of the types of
portrait behavior is as male male
courtship Behavior basically you know
homosexual courtship and uh what what
there was one study uh I don't think I
shared it in the original uh Twitter
thread because I was focusing on humans
but this one study also found that among
individuals who are prone to elevated
rates of male male courtship
their relatives also have uh you know
increased reproductive Fitness and so
there's you know we've seen in in fruit
flies uh a a pattern that is that is
consistent with the data we've seen in
humans and the data that we've seen in
evolutionary modeling and they all seem
to agree that yes this is something that
can explain the existence of male
homosexuality and and then of course
there's at least one paper by uh I
believe it was by Andrea uh compario
Kiani and I hope I'm not butchering that
name I've only seen it written so like
some of the names in the literature I
don't know if I'm pronouncing correctly
but uh but uh
uh Andrea compario Kiani has done a lot
of research on homosexuality in one of
the papers from 2017.
finds a similar Trend in the case of
female homosexuality
and so there's a lot of work left to
kind of fill in the Gap that's missing
in terms of the data to explain female
homosexuality there's kind of a sexist
bias in in the research literature
unfortunately but from from a little
from what little data we have seen so
far it does seem to be that that there
there may be or I would say even likely
is a similar explanation for
homosexuality regardless of which sex
you're looking at yeah
so I I might have actually over
complicated things when I was trying to
summarize this a second ago because I
guess
I guess even if you do have one gene
that's causing the the trait
if that one gene when in a female causes
her to have far more children than the
average female
but when in males sometimes causes them
to be homosexual
then it would be selected for a natural
section would be promoting it because
it's it's the math works out so that
well still you're having more kids
overall like this gene on average causes
the host to have more offspring even
though it takes a hit every several
Generations because it ends up in a
um in a male that's that's now
homosexual and is not as reproductive
so you could actually have that as a
single Gene causing that
um
but have
has there been research on specific
alleles like do we have a list of
alleles that are associated with
homosexuality like where they've found
this point mutation in this point
mutation is linked to homosexuality
uh yeah so they they have at least two
to a limited extent
um I I mentioned that there are some
genome-wide Association studies yeah and
uh so to like as a real uh hopefully
simple enough overview that doesn't
complicate it too much
a genome-wide Association study is a
type of study where you look at a really
large number of people in the population
that all have something in common right
this could be uh you know high blood
pressure or in in our case it could be
you know sexual orientation or
alcoholism you know you you look at a
really large number of people in the
population that all have something in
common uh and this is often favored for
really complex traits where it's not
super easy to figure out what's the
mechanism causing this right because
things like uh like whether it's uh
you know a a risk of developing a
certain type of disorder or whether it's
uh
you know something like blood pressure
or some other metabolic uh Factor like
you know cholesterol or sexual
orientation you know these or you know
even various other personality traits
you know these are all complex traits
that are likely the result of a
culmination of multiple different
genetic factors yeah and so one of the
ways of trying to try to figure out well
what are those genetic factors is to
take a really large number of people
from the population and then
basically look at at uh the how their
DNA varies you know and if if there is a
genetic component then what you'll see
out of all that data
um and the data is generally going to be
some sort of like sequencing data yeah
or or there there's specific
experimental strategies that you can uh
Implement to identify like what are the
mutations that vary from person to
person uh these would be called single
nucleotide polymorphisms it just means
that a single nucleotide within the DNA
is is a polymorphic or that it varies
from person to person
and uh and so so there's there's uh
generally going to be some sort of large
amount of genetic data that allows us to
see how how does the DNA sequence vary
from person to person and then we can
compare people that hell have a certain
type of trait that we're interested in
common and compare it to some other
group that doesn't have that trade so
for example we could compare gay people
to straight people or people with high
blood pressure to low blood pressure and
any genetic uh components that are
playing a role in determining that trait
we're going to see some uh we're we're
going to expect to see some statistical
correlation where you know people that
have let's say within the DNA sequence
on a certain chromosome at a certain
location like in a certain Gene
maybe the nucleotide at that position is
an A or an adenine uh and maybe it's
much much statistically less likely that
it's an A in someone else who doesn't
have that trait right so you're just
looking at statistical correlations at
the DNA level and using that type of
approach there there have been at least
a couple of studies that have found that
yes there are genetic variations within
the human DNA within the human genome
that vary from person to person in a way
that is very highly statistically
correlated with sexual orientation yeah
you know and that doesn't
that doesn't tell us like
mechanistically all the all the details
of what's going on like how does the
information in the DNA translate to a
trait as complicated as human sexual
attraction right there's a lot of
details left to fill in but at the very
least we do see very strong statistical
evidence in the DNA that that there is a
genetic component
yeah
um
I got a question from infinite monkey
yeah sure it says can you dumb it down
for us non-biologists it sounds like
you're saying it's a genetic byproduct
so
um
I I think I think that question is about
the the earlier explanation so when the
sexual antagonistic hypothesis yeah so
instead of homosexuality being selected
for by natural selection and that's why
it's sticking around it's
it
the trait that that those genes code for
when in a female can increase her
ability to have children
in some way maybe they're making her
desire to have more children maybe
they're making her more sexual sexually
active
and when that same gene that makes that
can make a mother more reproductively
successful ends up in a male it can in
some cases cause homosexuality so it's
it's not being directly selected for
homosexuality is not being selected for
but that Gene that causes it is being
selected for
in a different context
I don't know if I clarified that or if
that was also
hard to follow but
uh yeah no I think I mean that makes
perfect sense I I I I suppose uh if if
you could indulge me for a second it
might help make sense to
um to it to a wider audience to look at
it in the following way yeah
one point I I actually really wanted to
um really emphasize in this conversation
was the idea that
uh you know I I think everyone kind of
has like a at least a basic
understanding of how natural selection
works right yeah um but the the point
that I really wanted to emphasize that
gets back to the to your point into the
question the listener's question
is that
uh
not every
like entity within a gene pool or not
every entity within a population
needs to have its own offspring in order
for that population to flourish right
like so I I mentioned a little while ago
earlier in the conversation that
mitochondrial DNA
uh faces an evolutionary dead end in
males right because mitochondrial DNA is
maternally inherited yeah and yet the
the sperm
still has mitochondria because it needs
to produce energy so that the sperm can
swim around right yeah and and so there
there's there's a biological function
that's being served there even though
it's an evolutionary dead end right and
and so
I guess in that case I just wanted to
make the point that like not every
entity needs to have its own uh
descendants in order for the overall
population to flourish you know other
examples would be like the somatic
tissue right like the
um
the the nerve cells and the muscle cells
in our bodies you know they don't
produce their own uh or sorry they don't
contribute their own DNA to the Next
Generation right it's it's the the
genetics for making like a muscle cell
or a nerve cell are inherited through
the sperm and the Egg they're not
inherited directly from nerve muscle
cells right and so uh you know to scale
up from like a molecular or cellular
level to an animal behavior level you
mentioned the example of like uh bees
and ants
um you know
obviously if we look at that at various
uh highly Social Animal societies like
bees and ants and termites or naked mole
rats you know some members of the
population are very reproductively
active other members of the population
help in some other way you know
Gathering resources or contributing in
some other way towards the reproductive
Fitness of the members of the population
that we produce yeah and so I think the
the really General point that I really
want to emphasize is that not every
member of a population needs to pass its
DNA onto the Next Generation in order
for the population to flourish right
because yeah it's possible to have
indirect benefits and so in the case of
homosexuality you know the idea here is
that you have a set of genetic factors
that
uh positively contribute to reproductive
uh proliferation in some numbers of the
population
and then in other members of the same
population it contributes to
homosexuality and it's the overall
combination of effects of those genetic
factors that are being favored by
natural selection uh you know and so
that's I think the main point and and
yeah
so in a way even though kin selection
and the sexual antagonism hypothesis
where kin selection is that you know gay
and bi gay and bisexual people are kind
of like helpers in the nest you know
kind of like the work the sterile worker
bees so to speak of the human population
and then the sexual antagonism
hypothesis is that homosexuality is like
a kind of a byproduct so to speak of
um genetic factors that increase uh
reproductive Earth rates among relatives
you know one thing that these both have
in common is that is that more General
point that not every member of a
population needs to pass on its DNA for
the population of flourish right because
there can be indirect effects that lead
to homosexuality and Direct effects that
are favored by natural selection and
everything gets passed on you know
across the population
um at a net level or as a net
consequence yeah exactly okay I I want
to try and rephrase this one more time
because it does look like I'm looking at
the comments and there's this concept is
a little bit confusing
so we have can when we're talking about
kin selection
which is what favors like you know
worker bees that don't ever reproduce
that is an actual adaptation the the
everyone's better off
in a b population if some individuals
are devoted specifically to work in the
hive
that is an adaptation
so you actually have natural selection
that is uh that is selecting for
actively selecting four individuals that
will not reproduce
that's one explanation for homosexuality
as well maybe uh in ancient tribal or
you know traditional tribal settings it
was it was beneficial to have
individuals who just decided not to
reproduce and all of their energy they
would still produce food like everybody
else did they would still hunt like
everybody else said they would still you
know do chores within the tribe like
everyone else did and so you get a net
gain of reproductive uh Fitness for that
lineage
um just like you do in bees so that's
one explanation for homosexuality it's
it's actually adaptive the other
explanation for homosexuality is that
it's a byproduct you have a gene that's
really successful in a female
and and then males it can cause
homosexuality
well if you have let's say you have a
mutation that causes females to be twice
as productive in having offspring
when that Gene is in a female and it
causes males to be half as as productive
when it's in them well that's the same
as having no mutation at all it's
neutral right
um yeah it balances out yeah it just
balances out it's just when it happens
to be in a male they're not going to
reproduce very much when it happens
being a female they're going to
reproduce a lot so if you just do the
math it it works out to be exactly the
same and that would be
that's how we would explain
homosexuality as a byproduct of a gene
that works really well
in females right
so
hopefully that's that's clear now and
even if even if we do view it as as a
byproduct uh right that doesn't that's
not mutually
uh exclusive with like other
explanations yeah the the point here is
that let's say for the sake of argument
that uh that explanation which again
that's the one that as far as I can see
from the literature seems to have the
most evidence
um
let's say that that's the case right
that you have a set of genetic factors
that increase birth rates among some
people and then it increases the
likelihood of being gay among their uh
closely related relatives yeah and then
everything balances out and that's why
homosexuality persists
um under that situation though
even though gay people are less likely
on average to to reproduce on the you
know for themselves or to have their own
kids
um they can still contribute to society
in other ways right so that they can
still even even without having to rely
on the kin selection explanation per se
people have you know complex animal
societies like bees and ants as well as
humans
all you know all have in common the
tendency to form divisions of labor
right and that's one of the ways
that we flourish so well right and so
yeah uh it it could very well be that
there's a combination of different
explanations in fact that's uh that
seems to be the case that that we need
multiple different hypotheses to be true
in order to account for all the data we
see yeah and and so one of those
explanations is that like yeah even even
if we take homosexuality as a as a
byproduct of genetic traits that
increase
birth rates among their relatives
well then you know that doesn't rule out
cane selection it doesn't rule out uh
people who are gay and bisexual who
don't have their own kids yeah you know
contributing to the flourishing of
society in other ways right I
um I I feel like uh
the
it's worth pointing out that it's it's
really difficult for us to tell whether
or not homosexuality is an adaptation
Akin selected adaptation versus a
byproduct because right now this all the
societies that we live in are so
different from the societies that
existed in the past
um it's not clear to me how quickly our
genes could respond like let's suppose
for example that just just for the sake
of argument that this is that
homosexuality is kin selection
and it evolved in small tribal groups
well now we would live in a society that
works completely different we use money
so there's no there's no more like in a
tribe there's kind of it's Tit for Tat
behaviors you
you help other members of your group
because they've been helping you and you
form these personal relationships these
strong reputations now we use money as a
symbol instead of these reputations to
decide who gets the goods that were
produced by the group so we quickly
switched how everything works
and it's really hard for us to even
study this like the Adaptive nature of
homosexuality in modern culture because
modern culture is so dramatically
different from the culture where this
likely would have evolved in so uh I I
think I think that the cleanest
explanation
because of that is that
uh that this is a byproduct right rather
than
um kin selection but I have seen quite a
few people I know uh
uh Wilson the
O Wilson EO Wilson he proposed
homosexuality as being uh uh can
selected trait in humans
um it's a lot of uh you know
deep thinking biologists have have
proposed that but it's very hard to
prove
and so we got off topic a little bit
because we were talking about
um actual
actual uh observed mutations that are
associated with homosexuality uh my
understanding of these trying to trying
to link a mutation to a specific trait
in humans my understanding is that uh
it's incredibly difficult unless it's
super obvious so there are certain
things like duchenne Muscular Dystrophy
and we really understand the mutation
that causes that dwarfism of
is that the official word for it um
I I forget that there's there's like two
different types of mutations that can
cause dwarfism in humans there's several
others that cause it commonly in dogs
and so on like these things we've been
able to pinpoint because the effect is
so dramatic and in these cases like a
gene whose function we understand is
completely broken like that that Gene
just breaks in the case of uh dwarfism
in dogs there's actually there's a
duplication of a gene that causes the
the long bones to fuse too early and
because we understand the genetics well
enough and exactly what they do we can
say that is the cause for this trait
but in most cases that's nearly
impossible to do because we don't
understand enough about the link between
genotype and phenotype
how confident are you in these types of
or what is what is this the the
confidence among scientists about these
correlations between these specific
genetic markers and homosexuality is it
strong or is it weak
uh right okay so
um the statistical correlations from
like genome-wide Association studies at
least the the few that I've seen and
again I can I can share the papers that
yeah I'm referencing here uh show a
strong statistical correlation or some
loci some some locations within the
human genome now
going all the way back almost 30 years
now going back to like the early 90s
it's been
um
it's been shown at least by by a few
different studies in fact this is one of
the one one of the uh genetic factors
contributing to to male homosexuality
has most
reproducibly been uh linked to the X
chromosome and not only the X chromosome
but a specific region of the X
chromosome that's very close to the end
of the chromosome on I believe it's the
long arm it's the
xq28 region of the X chromosome so like
it's just one little region of the X
chromosome
that's close to the end of the
chromosome it's called the sub telomeric
region because like telomeres are like
the little
um and you almost think of them as like
the like the yeah the Caps uh you know
like the little plastic caps on the end
of your shoelaces it's like that for
chromosomes
um
and and within this region of the X
chromosome they're uh there seems to be
something going on that is being uh
statistically linked to homosexuality
and this is a finding that's been shown
in multiple studies
um and then also chromosome eight uh and
and then there's a few other scattered
across the human genome there's a few
other loci that have been uh that have
been shown to be statistically
correlated with homosexuality yeah now
as far as like what's what's the
like you know uh what's the missing
piece of the story that says okay here's
some
you know genetic factors and then over
here is homosexuality you know what's
going on in between that causes
the DNA to be expressed in a way that
contributes to homosexuality
uh there is at least one study I can I
can think of and this is again one of
the ones that I shared in the Twitter
thread where
uh after the genome-wide association
study that I mentioned was done that
found
that certain regions of the DNA are
statistically correlated with
homosexuality
there was actually a follow-up study
that said that
for these uh genetic factors that are
correlated with homosexuality
they also happen to be correlated among
sorry correlated with a tendency
among heterosexual people to have a
larger number of sex partners and
and so there's there's a correlation
that goes in both directions you know
once on one hand you have
sorry there's there's a set of genetic
factors and on one hand you have a
statistical correlation with uh the
likelihood of being homosexual and on
the other hand for those who are not
homosexual but still have the same
genetic factors there's a statistical
correlation with the likelihood of
having more sex partners and so this is
again one of those additional pieces of
evidence that seems to show that the
genetic factors that
uh contribute to a likelihood of
homosexuality also contribute to a
likelihood of higher birth traits yeah
among among relatives and
um you mentioned that like one of the
possible ways to explain that is uh like
a behavioral phenomenon you know perhaps
uh the genetic factors are leading to
like just being a more attracted being
more attracted to males okay and maybe
that just makes uh women heterosexual
women more sexually active and then it
makes men more likely to be gay right um
that that has been proposed as an
explanation I just want to point out
that that's not like the only
explanation you know there's been one
study from about 10 years ago that also
found that
the that the the female relatives of
homosexual men also on average had fewer
gynecological disorders and fewer
pregnancy complications so there could
be like physiological as in addition to
where perhaps even instead of Behavioral
explanations but the underlying
evolutionary explanation would be the
same yeah yeah just the numbers shake
out so that it's even though it it'll
make it'll cause homosexuality every
every so often it's
it's
benefits
and when I say benefit I mean I'm just
talking about reproductive benefits far
outweigh that so
yeah right
that's really interesting it's what what
I'm finding is that I'm kind of
uncomfortable talking about this because
I don't want to say something that
sounds uh like when I want to talk about
like beneficial or that the cost there's
um
something can be beneficial
for uh Evolution but also can be like
unpleasant socially and vice versa
something can be a problem as far as
spreading your genes goes but can
actually cause an individual to live
much more uh
pleasurable life or um satisfying life
so it's uh I do want to be clear with
that like when we're talking about the
evolution of these things we're talking
it if a trait is good and evolutionary
biology that means that it helps
increase reproductive Fitness if it's
bad it means that it reduces
reproductive Fitness but that does not
correlate to what we would actually
think is good or bad in our lifetimes
you know it's a it's good for a female
praying mantis to eat the head of its of
its lover because she's going to have
more more babies but if that's the thing
that people were doing we would say that
that's bad and we would want to stop
that from happening so there's not um
you're talking about the the what the
the malthusian the
um language here gets a little bit yeah
a little bit uh complicated
right yeah and you might have noticed
from my uh you you mentioned that you've
looked at my graduate work when I was
getting my PhD and like one of the
things that really interested me uh
during graduate school and and I an
interest I continued to hold is the
phenomenon of cooperation right and and
like the the sort of The Duality between
cooperation and conflict you know and
the reason I bring that up is because
like
on on one hand I I agree with your point
that like
a trait that maybe is beneficial from
the point of view of evolution is
perhaps not beneficial from the point of
view of a person that has that trait
um or vice versa
however on the other hand
I I just I guess I want to like
emphasize that like one of the reasons
for the evolutionary flourishing of
of us and many other species of animal
is a tendency to cooperate and work
together for the common good right and
uh you know that's that's you know
basically a major component of the
explanation for for kin selection right
is that
uh you know some some genes are more
easily passed on to Future Generations
specifically because animals are working
together and helping each other survive
right and so in that sense
um there's some level at which I think
the distinction between what's good from
our own point of view and what's good
from an evolutionary point of view that
distinction can break down in some
respects and it specifically breaks down
I think in the context of
um like one of the things that's in our
benefit both evolutionarily and
um personally is is working together and
forming uh you know Cooperative
interactions basically mutually
beneficial Cooperative interactions
right yeah well one of the examples of
uh of a trait an evolved trait that's
being selected for that's actually
really uh traumatic for the organisms
that possess it and dogs when they mate
the
the
erectile tissue in the male dog inflates
so much that they can't they can't
separate afterwards they're stuck
together so a lot of I noticed a lot of
Americans don't know this but if if you
go to South America you go anywhere
where there's a lot of wild you know
stray dogs you'll see it all the time
there's oh there's those two dogs are
stuck to each other that's weird
um and like our dogs uh when they mate
they fight afterwards so they're stuck
together and then so Zoe my female
she'll get angry at him for being stuck
inside of her and she'll fight him and
it she'll knock him over I mean it's
brutal like that's it's it's really
brutal and one of the reasons that we
think that this evolved is because
there's so much mate guarding in dogs
when when you have a female who is
supposed she thinks that she's the one
that's supposed to be reproducing the
other females or not when she sees other
pairs mating in the in the group she
will break them up she'll try and rip
them apart and we think that this
evolves so that she couldn't do that so
so the um I see it's a extremely
unpleasant trait it can cause serious
injuries in the mail actually in the
male and the female but it evolved
because it helps reproduction so you get
yeah you can get the evolution of these
these traits that are
um yeah unpleasant for individuals and
vice versa but yeah
that's a little bit yeah uh I think a
good example in in humans is uh has to
do with the evolution of pregnancy right
and like yeah
there's definitely like uh
almost like a
Evolution kind of has to like thread the
needle between as you know
humans have evil you know culture and
Tool making you know we uh you know we
have a larger cerebral cortex than like
our closest uh relatives in the form of
you know chimpanzees and bonobos you
know and that can potentially lead to
pregnancy complications right and uh
right so like yeah like just like you
mentioned there's there's similar
parallels not the not the same exact
example that you mentioned but there are
evolutionarily similar parallels in in
US
uh we've got a couple of questions that
have been building up here and we're at
we're at 350. I I don't want to cut you
off though because so
did we discuss most of the things that
you wanted to discuss
uh yeah I think so I think the main
point I wanted to hit was like if
all the details get get lost or or you
know um
or you don't remember I think the main
point is that like
not every member in a population needs
to reproduce in order for the population
to flourish right and so like
uh it's just I I think that's an
important point to keep in mind because
it's often
argued at least in my experience people
often argue that like homosexuality is
unnatural and it should be discouraged
because it it's a form of like uh or
because like homosexual sex doesn't lead
to reproduction yeah and it's like well
so what that doesn't mean that it's
unnatural because we see examples all
across the different levels of
biological organization from cellular to
uh animal society and in many different
contexts where individuals within a
population can flourish just fine and
the population itself can flourish just
fine because of a reproductive division
of labor where some members are
reproducing and others aren't you know
and that's
you know Evolution can favor that very
easily yeah you know I think that's
that's an important thing to keep in
mind right
yeah
so it's it really that when people have
an evolutionary issue
with homosexuality it comes from just
having an overly simplified idea of how
natural selection works you can you can
get selection to favor individuals who
are not reproductively active
exactly
um
let's do
uh Okay it's 3 52 here so what time is
it over there
uh it's 352 here
okay
let's do
um
oh yeah you're sorry I thought you were
in California but yeah you're in New
York right
right yeah
um
how much time do you have to answer a
couple questions here
oh I'm good however long it takes okay
let's see
um
YouTuber the higher Evolution did a
Super Chat thank you I appreciate that
um if I'm I'm trying to go through here
and just look at questions but I'm kind
of a slow reader when I'm okay uh
broadcasting so for people who if you if
you put your questions earlier in the
chat just put uh paste them again so I
can see them
but we've got let's see
Max Max mccaffel asks what are my other
questions
how do those human studies account for
oppression and discrimination and
populations we're only studying the out
self-identified gay
individuals seems like a potential bias
um
so I yeah I guess that's that's about
these questions the or these studies
like how do we know that we're actually
actually studying
and getting the true numbers of
homosexual
like how common it is if
these societies you're oppressing
homosexuality therefore people are going
to be shy to talk about it
right yeah that's that's actually a
really really excellent point you know
and it's one of the reasons why in some
societies we have very limited data on
the prevalence of of uh homosexuality
and bisexuality right like um
there's still to this day for some
reason uh we have societies where it's
uh illegal for people of the same sex to
have you know physical intimacy and
um so in in a society like that if you
wanted to do a study on the prevalence
of homosexuality you're going to be
hard-pressed to find to be able to
recruit participants in that study yeah
and and so the the question of the the
person that asks this question brings up
an excellent point and that is that is a
very serious problem I completely agree
um that being said though
so they're
there there is
still I would say
uh a couple of things in favor of some
of the data we're seeing like I like the
the problem of the data being very
limited I think is really just a problem
being able to
um well I mean it leads to a problem I
should say of being able to
um have the the the amount of data that
we would need to really be able to put
some of these questions to rest in terms
of like
what are the different evolutionary
explanations that are perhaps most
relevant in contributing to the
prevalence and the Persistence of
homosexuality
um
but from from the data that we have seen
some of the uh explanations that we have
like for example the the example that
the explanation that we've talked about
most here in terms of uh
homosexuality being genetically linked
to elevated birth rates among the the
relatives of gay and bisexual people
you know that type of explanation uh has
data that supports it that comes from
study from independent studies of people
in different societies and so like yeah
even though the the data is very limited
and we would very much like to have more
data in in order to get that of course
we would very much need to have
you know perhaps
uh a more favorable and a more welcoming
culture to the lgbtq community and this
is like I said it's especially true in
many societies where it's culturally
frowned upon or it's illegal and it's
more heavily discriminated against
um but you know so so on one hand like I
I think the question asker makes a
really excellent point but on the other
hand I don't think that it is uh
a problem in terms of like casting doubt
on the what we what we see to be the
leading explanations because we do still
see uh like a a consistent reproducible
effect of of the sorry the the type of
data that is supportive of that
explanation for homosexuality has been
reproducibly uh like it's reproducibly
shown up in the literature yeah and so I
would I would still say that like yeah
the the evidence that we have strongly
supports the the leading hypotheses
nevertheless yes the the it's tragically
the case that we have very limited data
still yeah so even with the data that we
have we we see that there's a very clear
signal here
and of yeah of course it must be um
it must be uh
higher than reported in some countries
like if you were to go to a country
where you're executed for homosexual
Behavior obviously people are not gonna
want to participate in that study right
or you're going to get less right yeah
being open
uh we've got a we've got a question that
I think was asked in total sincerity but
uh some people might find this offensive
and so I I do think we should just talk
about this
um
the question of whether or not
homosexuality is a disorder a
neurological disorder
and this is this is interesting it
actually has very little to do with
evolutionary biology but it has to do
with how people classify things
um homosexuality was classified in the
past as a psychological disorder and
that was changed I believe like
in the 70s because this really is a
what do humans who are in charge of
uh Medical Science textbooks want to
decide to call this right
I don't know if you if you know much of
the history on that or
a little bit so I'll go ahead and start
with the caveat that I'm not a mental
health expert by any means
um and in fact I'm I'm not uh a
researcher on sexual orientation right
my field is more General evolutionary
biology and evolutionary theory
um
that that being said though
like you mentioned it's been almost 50
years now since the American Psychiatric
association uh stopped referring to
uh homosexuality as a mental disorder
you know and a big part of the reason
for that is that
um there are like specific
uh sets of diagnostic criteria that
irrespective of the how a disorder
manifests like you know there are
different types of mental disorders that
people can have irrespective of of the
specifics of how those mental disorders
um are different from each other
they nevertheless there's nevertheless
is is a like set of diagnostic criteria
in terms of like a person's ability to
to like you know function basically so
to speak like you know hold down a job
um you know and maintain healthy
relationships with other people for
example and right
um and and so again I'm not a mental
health expert but I do know that you
know I can say you know confidently that
like there's you know specific criteria
that have to be made in order to be able
to say that yes this is a mental
disorder and that that's the case when
we're not speaking specifically about
sexual orientation like when we're just
talking about mental health in general
yeah and then as we began to understand
sexual orientation
um like more more thoroughly because
like the the detail sorry the research
on sexual orientation really started to
ramp up in like the 60s and 70s and 80s
and as we started to get more data and
more information about homosexuality
um it became clear that
homosexuality same-sex attraction and a
tendency to have same-sexual
relationships it really doesn't meet any
of those diagnostic criteria about
mental illness and a lot of the uh a lot
of the traits or qualities of gay people
that do meet those diagnostic criteria
can be attributed to other things like
for example gay people uh you know gay
and bisexual people in general
well I'm sorry I should back up the
lgbtq community entirely I know we
haven't been talking about like gender
identity but yeah across the board lgbtq
community in general has elevated rates
of things like uh tendency for uh
suicide and uh substance abuse and
um you know depression and anxiety and
and these you know very clearly do meet
the uh at least in many cases for many
people they do rise to the level of
needing diagnostic criteria for Mental
Illness but then at the same time these
traits can also be attributed to things
like societal societal discrimination
right and uh one of the things that's
been seen in in the literature is that
the uh the mental health outcomes of
people who are gay and bisexual is uh is
something that is responsive to the
surrounding Society so like yeah people
who live in people who are gay and
bisexual who live in places where
Society is more low welcoming and more
affirmative and we're like same-sex
marriage is legal for example we see
lower rates of you know substance abuse
and suicide and
the other indicators of mental illness
and so I think that's really strong
evidence that uh the the aspects of or
the the qualities that are common among
the lgbtq community that meet the
conditions of mental illness
can't be attributed to uh
sexual orientation or gender identity
per se they have other societal causes
and so in that respect I would say yeah
it's
um it's it's basically outdated
information to refer to sexual to
homosexuality as a mental disorder
that's you know that hasn't really been
the case for over 50 years now and the
research has progressed and as we've
gotten more information we we have more
more clarity and more detail on
on on what it is about the mental health
of the lgbtq community and why uh you
know what are the causes of of
uh you know
uh things that are that are risk factors
to mental health and it's it's not the
sexual orientation itself it's a whole
bunch of other factors yeah
yeah I mean that
I obviously in a homosexual relationship
you're not going to have kids so the
well you're not gonna have kids if if
you only have sexual relations with your
partner in a homosexual monogamous
situation
so
you could this is an example where we
can consider something to be
um less evolutionarily fit than a
heterosexual phenotype right
but that's not the same as saying that
it's a disorder because you've got
people that can live happy wonderful
productive healthy lives and homosexual
relationships homosexual pairs
so right yeah in fact there's a lot of
literature actually on on parenting
among lgbtq people sorry I'm getting off
on a little bit about that but like one
of the
uh one of the uh I guess collections of
literature that I've been building up
his um research on parenting outcomes
and like
you know consistently study after study
after study it's it's reproducibly shown
like reliably reproducibly shown that
that uh
there is
really no uh
difference between same-sex couples and
heterosexual couples when it comes to
the long-term outcomes like in terms of
school performance or mental health
outcomes for example of the kids that
they raise of their children yeah okay
yeah yeah so with adoption and so on
um
yeah
uh let's see I'm looking at questions
here
infinite monkey asks it's a consistent
percentage range in the data right so I
think he's asking about uh the the
percentage of homosexual orientation is
is consistent and yes it seems to be
cross-culturally consistent
from society to society but the thing
that is consistent is that it seems to
be within a range like yeah you know mid
to Upper single digits you know like
depending on the society you look at I
think it's higher like in the
Philippines than it is in India for
example but it you know generally for
most societies somewhere between three
and eleven percent uh are are the
numbers that are being reported in in
the research literature
[Music]
let's see
I think that is all of the questions
directly related to This research we've
got some
Rachel light asks curious if you guys
have seen those two documentaries on the
PBS YouTube channel sorry I got to
figure out which one which two you're
talking about
um
two documentaries from PBS Science
Channel on the possibility of the
disappearing Y chromosome I have not
watched those
I don't know if you've if you're
familiar with that
I've seen I haven't seen the documentary
I've seen some some talk in the
literature of of uh like the atrophy of
the Y chromosome yeah yeah in fact I
mean some species of animals don't even
have a y chromosome it's like
um whether they're a male or not is just
the presence or absence of a second copy
of the X chromosome right and
um and so like yeah it doesn't really
surprise me but that's also I can't
really speak to the to the documentary
or what's what's being claimed in the
yeah yeah it seems like over
evolutionary time the sex chromosome uh
like
the sex chromosome setups that that
influence an individual's sex being male
or female those can like kind of like
under under the hood things can swap out
and change quite a bit over evolutionary
time and it's like on the Y chromosome
there's only a handful of genes that are
really important on that chromosome and
sometimes those will end up on an X
chromosome so there's there's uh
definitely possibilities that you could
completely get rid of the Y chromosome
and still have males and females in a
population
I just exactly yeah it would take a long
time it's we don't expect that to happen
um
like in our lifetimes but that that
could certainly
that could happen and it wouldn't um
it would happen without disrupting
the male female mating system
right exactly step by step
um I think that I believe that is all
the questions that we have
I'm gonna I'm gonna go over this one
more time real quick just to make sure
but while I'm looking over this do you
want to just uh tell us any any parting
words
uh any last thoughts well I don't know
if it's a if it's a good way to to wrap
up like the entire the entirety of the
conversation but on that last point you
mentioned like
um
the like look you I think you mentioned
something about like the swapping of
genetic information between chromosomes
yeah uh and that's something that we we
definitely see in other contexts right
like I I can't remember if we were
already uh streaming live when we when I
mentioned this point but like the
mitochondria or like the distant
descendants of what were once pre-living
bacteria and
you know mitochondria have continued to
retain their own DNA but the
mitochondrial genome has also been
getting paired down in size especially
in animals and like a lot of the genes
that are encoded by that were once
encoded by mitochondrial DNA have been
translocated to the nucleus and are now
encoded you know the the genes are
expressed off of the nuclear genome and
then the proteins are synthesized by the
ribosomes so then imported back into the
mitochondria and there's you know
there's evolutionary reasons for for why
that it makes sense to do it that way
but nevertheless like we see like a kind
of an evolutionary pruning down of the
size of the mitochondrial genome yeah
and so that's just another example that
that kind of mirrors what's been
suggested to be the case for the Y
chromosome
uh that the final question I was able to
find in here it's a question about twin
studies I guess we did kind of jump over
this uh what we see that there's there's
if one identical twin is gay the percent
that the other one will be gay is higher
than in uh
fraternal twins so
that's correct what do you do you know
off the top of your head what that
percentage is how strong of a
correlation that is
I off the top of my head I you know I
want to say it was in the mid double
digits I thought I think it was like 30
30 40 likelihood if one is gay that the
other is going to be gay but um again I
uh don't quote me on that because
um I'm gonna have to consult the
literature and make sure but also this
is something that's been looked at like
in multiple studies and so you're going
to see different uh
but some some variation from study to
study uh on what that exact percentage
is the overall trend though that it is
more likely to be the case for identical
twins than fraternal twins that part is
uh is is consistently found but uh the
specific numbers are going to vary a
little bit between studies yeah and um
the uh I guess
one of the points that has been made in
the past
that I think might be relevant to your
listeners is that
identical twins are sometimes uh treated
differently than fraternal twins like
they might look more similarly and that
might affect the way they're raised and
so even in the case of identical twins
some people might shrug that off and say
okay well it still doesn't prove that
it's genetic
and in fact uh even twin studies in
general like people point to as people
sometimes point to as evidence that
homosexuality isn't genetic because you
know hey look here's a twin that's
straight in another and and here's a
person that's straight in that twin
that's okay that doesn't that prove that
it's not genetic and like no it's it's
more complicated than that and and you
know the
the strongest evidence that it's genetic
I would say it comes from like those
genome-wide Association studies but
again like the those are more recent and
the older evidence from comparing like
you said identical twins versus
fraternal twins you know that
whether the twins are identical or
fraternal that affects the likelihood
that they're going to share the same
sexual orientation and so yeah I I would
say that that General trend is is
consistent in the literature but the
specific percentages are going to vary
yeah yeah the the percentage that he had
seen was 30 so that that okay cool
that's interesting
I I am not familiar with those studies
but
um
well
I guess uh yeah any any final summary
that you'd like to give
as we wrap this up
um
yeah so I guess the other the main two
points uh that I mentioned I think I
mentioned like in in private
conversation that I wanted to hit was
like that
something being genetic
doesn't mean that there's deterministic
you know oh this person has this Gene
therefore they have this trait like
genes interact with their environment
right like yeah
you know it's we shouldn't think of it
as a nature versus nurture debate it's
like we should be thinking of it in
terms of trying to figure out well no
it's both but how do nature and nurture
interact and it's the interaction it's
in that interaction and the complexity
of that interaction where we find the
answers and
and so that's the main point or is that
like something being genetic doesn't
mean genetic determinants is true and
then because environment plays a huge
role and then the other point is that
uh
not every member of a population needs
to reproduce
you know or needs to pass on its own DNA
for the population to flourish because
you know the study of evolution if it's
proven anything it's proven that
um that a population can thrive on a
reproductive division of labor whereby
the DNA gets passed on very successfully
specifically because there's a division
of labor where some members reproduce
and other members contribute to society
in other ways and homosexuality could
very well be one of those ways or sorry
one you know one manifestation of that
of that tendency
and uh and again you know sexual
antagonism where some members had
elevated birth rates and then the
genetic traits that contribute to that
also contribute to homosexuality among
relatives you know that's one perfect
example of this
more General point where not everyone
needs to reproduce for the population of
Polish yeah I guess now if you want to
look at that same argument from the
genes I view you could say that uh a
gene doesn't need every individual it
ends up in to reproduce it needs a
certain percentage of them to reproduce
in order to persist in the population it
just needs to be uh relevant compared to
other versions of itself it needs to be
able to compete with them but that
doesn't require making every single
person it's in reproduce it can make
some reproduce extra and others
reproduce not at all and that extra will
allow it to persist so exactly
well thanks this was this was a lot of
fun I mean this is just a topic that's
it's difficult to talk about uh because
of you know just all the social uh
you know it gets political and so on but
I I this is really fun to just look at
the data and talk about this
um again this is a question that I get a
lot and I just don't really know how to
deal with it so I'm really glad you came
on to help uh I've got your Twitter is
on screen right now I've got I'm gonna
have links to your your Twitter in the
video description I'm gonna have links
to the papers that you send uh as well
so people can do some more reading on
their own but
thank you Brian I look forward to seeing
what you publish in the future and uh
how your your research goes continuing
forward
yeah thanks I appreciate you having me
on this has been a lot of fun cool
so long everybody
bye everyone
all right
thanks that was fun